alright I'm Cindy joystick I'm an
associate professor of biomedical
engineering at the University of
Michigan in Ann Arbor today I'm going to
talk about carbon fiber electrode arrays
I am going to start by going through my
favorite application of neural probes
because I can't resist talking about
motor neuron prosthetics so I'm gonna
give that as an example of usefulness of
having a very high density array of
neural probes then I'm gonna talk about
the history of carbon fiber array
development and some of the literature
that led up to some of the work that
we've been able to do and then finally
I'm going to talk about the carbon fiber
electrode arrays that we have developed
as part of our brain initiative work as
a neuroscience tool so let me get
started by talking about new motor
neuroprosthetics
so what do I mean by that specifically I
mean that we take signals from the brain
of the nerves or muscles and we want to
use those signals to try to extract a
motor control signal so for example in
the case of amputation we might want to
take a signal from the nerves or muscles
and use that to control a prosthetic
hand you could also imagine the case of
spinal cord injury where we want to be
able to get signals from the brain and
use that to control electrical
stimulation of a paralyzed arm somebody
goes through an example of each of these
and talk about what electrodes are used
today and where there's opportunities to
be better in the future
so let me start with nerve controlled
prosthetic hands so the Empire Strikes
Back came out in 1980 and had this
really compelling science fiction
picture of nerves controlling a
prosthesis in real life it's
unfortunately even really hard to get a
valuable control signal directly from
and the reason for that is you know
despite lots of very intelligent
hard-working people trying to get that
signal it's just that the physics is not
in your favor for doing that because the
nerve is just so small you know you're
talking about nerves that are about a
millimeter in diameter and you're gonna
have to stick a wire inside of that
nerve in order to pick up that signal
and so you know does this can be done
and fairly controlled or at least short
term conditions but you know even though
the signal is really small and it's hard
to get a realistic signal and a person
walking around and you're very limited
by how many electrodes you can currently
put into a nerve because it causes a a
scarring response which I'll talk more
about later in my group I think we
decided that it was so hard to get a
signal from a nerve we sort of found a
way around it in the case of amputation
where because we can't record from that
nerve we instead attach a small piece of
muscle to the end of an amputated nerve
and you can get multiple signals this
way by dividing the nerve down into
different branches but the what you
really gain from wrapping a piece of
muscle around the nerve is that the
nerve regenerates into the muscle and
creates a much bigger signal inside the
muscle but you also gain on the
electrode side because now I can use an
electrode very similar to what a cardiac
pacemaker uses so now that I have a
centimeter of muscle I can shove a one
millimeter probe inside of it but you
know this way it's limited because I can
only get one signal for each nerve
branch but it's actually pretty good in
terms of you know being better than what
state-of-the-art
so I'm gonna go ahead and play a video
of what we can do with just two signals
recorded from nerves and if you think
about it you're you can only move your
thumb based on muscles that are inside
of your hands and so this is something
we have to get
nerves
[Music]
okay
so down
but
over
down
okay so that's an example of what we can
do if we can get two independent signals
out of the nerves imagine what we could
do if we had even more signals because
we had a smaller electrodes and could
put more of them inside the nerves and
muscles so let me talk about another
application where we're using electrodes
to try to get across setec control
signals and so not only can we do this
from the nerves and muscles we can also
go directly to motor cortex and in the
case of spinal cord injury this is where
you have to go to get good control
signals to control the arm and hands so
what you're seeing there is it looks
very dramatic but in real life it's
about four by four millimeters and it
goes about a millimeter into the brain
this is called the Utah array and it
does a pretty good job of recording
neural signals and you know can last for
multiple years let me show you a picture
of what the surgery looks like there and
I would say this is a pretty darn good
electrode I tell you about new
electrodes but you know this this does a
pretty good job of reporting signals
from the brain and it absolutely
generates a scar but you know if every
video you've ever seen somebody
controlling something with a youth IRA
has been done after the period of
experimentation it's been in according
to a recent review article it's been in
48 young brains so it has a really good
safety record in my lab we use signals
from Utah arrays to control finger
movements so let me play a video here of
a monkey who has one of these Utah
raised in primary motor cortex and it's
what he's going to use those signals to
control an animated index finger so
the moving finger is being controlled
directly by brain signals so he also
knows how to do this task with his
wallet
you
okay
so I mentioned before that that those
signals were multiple months after
implants which means that they've
already generated what every
conventional electrode does when you put
in the brain which is it generates a
star so to sort of motivate why we need
probes let me talk about what that means
so the Utah array has elements that are
about 80 microns across and for
electrodes you know are around that
order of magnitude for you know made by
multiple vendors if you take that and
put it into the brain you are going to
generate a scoring response the brain
protects itself from foreign body news
and it detects that as a foreign body
and so what does that mean to us if we
are trying to record neural signals so
on the right is a figure from the tresco
lab and they're looking at the health of
the neurons and neural iment after long
term in class so right in the middle of
the slide if you can see the orange bar
that's the location that an electrode
was in and then in the top right pot you
see lots of blue dots and those blue
dots correspond to neurons and
unfortunately and you can see you know
on the right there's a lot of blue dots
but as you get closer and closer to that
orange bar there's many many fewer blue
dots and probably something very similar
happens when you put a Utah array in the
brain again it still has you know the
best safety record in human beings it's
been implanted many times but you know
this is the reason why we would not put
this in a healthy brain okay so that's
and that's a major problem with with
many different kinds of electrodes
and in fact I have to go 400 microns
away to get away from that as I'm
sparring and indeed the Utah array has a
pitch between the different electrodes
of 400 microns so if I want to get more
signals so I want to control more of the
fingers or generate you know control
multiple parts of the body I can't just
make my utah array more dense if i start
putting those closer together I'm
eventually going to turn the brain into
a solid block of scar tissue so that's
not a good path okay so before in before
I talk about you know how we're gonna
try to solve this problem let me just
talk a little bit about specifically why
is scarring a problem I think they're
sort of a a misconception that the
process of scar formation insulates the
electrode like that it electrically
insulates the electrode and I think you
know that that does happen but if that
is not the important thing that happens
so specifically you know and let's look
at how these signals get to our
electrode so if I have a black dot there
is an electrode and i am recording from
a field of neurons i can think of those
neurons as lots of current sources as
you know ions gets course then synced
into the you know into different
compartments of the neuron i'm going to
pick up an external voltage that
corresponds to those current sources and
sinks and it's actually you know it's a
fairly simple relationship so you know
it depends on the current so that's why
not it depends on the conductivity which
is that sigma and it also depends on the
distance to the electrode which is that
R and so you know with a scar you're
definitely going to increase the the
resistivity or decrease the conductivity
but first of all that it's not that big
a deal it's it's still tissue so it's
not exactly as insulating as a rubber
and we're actually talking about a
pretty high impedance probe the starch
so
the impedance associated with the scar
you know isn't isn't necessarily a big
problem we can handle the impedance of
the electrode the big problem that we
have however is the distance there as a
scar forms it's going to push those
electrodes away and as you see from the
equation it goes the voltage is
inversely proportional to the distance R
and 1 over 1 over R means that that
signal falls off extremely quickly as we
move away from the electrode
you
well that movie shows how far this
signal extends from the middle of the
neuron so the white dot is a neuron and
the the alleppey field that you can
actually record it doesn't extend for
more than about 25 microns on each side
so and this is from whole think of 1999
so this is a real problem if I'm trying
to record from neurons if that scar even
if even a small spark can push me 20
microns away we're just going to make my
signals much smaller than they would be
otherwise and a large scar say 50 to 100
microns is going to push all of the
neurons outside a range of my electorate
so I have to somehow deal with that
spurring response if I want to put my
electrodes closer together and
ultimately to put more electrodes into
brain and I should say what this means
is that all previous electrodes have in
a sense been operating with one hand
tied behind their back because the
scarring sets in and it's you know it's
known that this happens and it generally
happens before most experiments are done
on electrodes alright so that was the
state of affairs around 2005 right where
we didn't have any idea how to deal with
the scarring problem and you know it was
it was kind of a dark time because if it
was really unclear you know if there was
ever gonna be a way to stop that orrin
body response or at least minimize that
foreign body response so that we can
report from these neurons for a long
time period yeah so I think a solution
to the started emerging in the
literature around 2007 and there were
two very similar studies one published
by John Seymour in the kickee lab and
the other study published by schools in
at all in Patras code lab but the
results are very similar and support
each other as being a possible solution
so what you're looking at is two
conventional silicon probes
X
that they have a lattice element and
what's important about that lattice
element is that the individual
components of that lattice are 15
microns are smaller and at that size
it's actually smaller than a neuron and
what they found is that the number of
neurons surrounding the electrode was
much much higher around the small
elements so for example thinking this
terms goes in it all around the 15
micron lattice elements there was 85
percent of normal density compared to
the solid part of the electrode where
there was only 35 percent normal and
there on density but it was pretty
typical for a froot so this is an
enormous effect there there are 50% more
neural tom of the neurons that were
missing around these small elements and
this really suggests that you know what
we should be doing is making these
electrodes very very small so that
that's great but if you'll notice that
if I if I took those lattice probes and
if I stuck a hundred of those into the
brain they're actually doing damage on
the way down so they're still sort of
have the profile of our like they were
electrode so that's you know ripping up
circuitry that that I would rather not
rip up and so the key is gonna be how do
we put something if 15 microns or
smaller into the brain and do that in a
way that that's the only thing entering
the brain and it does very little damage
on the way going all right so my lab and
others is the tempting to solve this
problem using one of these strongest
materials that we have access to as
engineers and I specifically mean carbon
fiber I took this from a textbook and it
does a really good job describing will
be cool materials properties we get from
using carbon fiber it has eyes
strengthening sellstrom high Young's
modulus it has that 15 years us then
it's actually really electrically
conductive so you know it serves really
well as a wire it also has good chemical
stability and excellent resistance to
acids alkalis and many solvents and I
won't get into that here but that
actually is a really important process a
really important thing for surviving in
the brain you know maybe one day for
decades so short version of that is
strong and cheap certainly at low
volumes and the other thing is that it's
a really you know it's an easy material
to handle and despite it being really
hard like being very stiff and that's
gonna help us insert into the brain it's
also very durable and harder to break
than most of the other common electrode
materials so I want to play a video here
of carbon fibers embedded in silicon and
we're gonna run them over with the glass
capillary which we can do ten thousand
times without breaking the electrodes
okay so admittedly that's from when we
invented it silicon on if we put it on
something yes that's gonna be a little
bit more breakable but in general these
this is a material that is much easier
to work whereas and will survive a
surgical handling pretty well so the
first so first of all I should say that
carbon fibers have been around for
Neuroscience for a really long time
particularly due to the seminal work of
Mark Whiteman they are commonly used for
recording neurotransmitters and this can
be done with something called Bastian
cyclic voltammetry so you know these
were around a lot of neuroscience labs
but the way that they were used is you
know the these are closer to the size of
cobwebs than hair so they're very small
and so they would normally be put inside
of a glass capillary and that makes them
easy to handle and insert into the brain
the first simulated probe by which I
mean you know just just the carbon fiber
and here we're talking about starting
with a seven micron carbon fiber the
first one was developed by a teacake
Rose eye and we still use a lot of his
manufacturing processes in the lab so
how do you build these is you start with
a bare carbon fiber and in you know in
proportion neurons are universally
bigger than seven microns they can vary
in size you know like ten to thirty
microns as the size of the neuron and
our carbon fiber is going to be much
smaller than that so it gets coated with
a layer of karoliina see and that's used
as an insulator because I don't want to
record from the whole carbon fiber I
just want to record from the tip and
then the tip is cut and we now do that
with a wide variety of techniques and in
EPA's initial paper this was done by P
dot there was also a layer of P dot
added to reduce the overall impedance
and that makes this a much better
electrode and that's what it looked like
in his 2012 nature materials paper so
this is a there's a very very small
electrode
and you could kind of get it into the
brain with tweezers you know with a lot
of coaxing and again you know you can do
that because it's carbon fiber or even
though it's so small but you know it was
it was fairly challenging to try to put
multiple of these electrodes in any
different surgery so in my lab we
developed this into an array so
specifically what you're looking at on
the upper left is our sort of model
device from 2015 that we use to
demonstrate a workable geometry and I
should say this was developed by my
former PhD student now postdoc first
patel and this followed several years of
having cobweb sized electrodes flopping
uselessly against the surface of the
brain but you know after a lot of trial
and error we've sort of figured out that
you know 500 microns is the magic number
where if you can take a micron carbon
fiber and you make it 500 microns or
shorter at that point you get 100%
success in penetrating the pia of the
brain which is that you know that's the
top layer of a rat so then we came up
with a number of ways to temporarily or
permanently have 500 microns of carbon
fiber and so what you're seeing there is
500 microns of carbon fiber at the tip
and then there's gradually widening so
again just so we can get you know the
other five hundred to a thousand microns
into motor cortex and I want to play the
video here where you're just gonna see
the carbon fiber disappear past the
surface of the brain and at least for
that first part of the video the brain
barely reacts
alright so that was one way of making
the carbon fibers 500 microns or less
another way that you know was was really
useful in a lot of applications is we
put a dissolvable material on the
electrodes so you can see that pictured
on the left and then you know you can
penetrate the frame with the first parts
and then you can melt off the rest of
the material as you go and so I should
say that it basically be the important
thing is to penetrate that top layer
called the pia once you're through the
pia you basically have your pilot hole
and it's holding the carbon fiber in
place and you can actually drive a
carbon fiber all the way through it at
that point so it's just that that first
layer of penetration that's that's
really important and I should also say
that longer than 500 microns carbon
fibers do penetrate but it's not a
hundred percent and if you want to put
an array of closely spaced electrodes
you need it to be absolutely a hundred
percent of the electorate that penetrate
because if one of them goes fibroids it
can take out the rest of your array
another device that we do a lot of work
with is pictured on the right that's
kind of our workhorse device where we
just have carbon fibers projecting off
the end of the circuit board and we can
actually put that in a handle so that
lets us get anywhere in the brain where
the cannula is obviously gonna do some
borage but you know the carbon fiber
extends 500 microns past bad and so you
know typically that's enough to get
outside of the damage radius of the
cannula and a lot of the you know the
early results we've seen or in recording
from neurons came from these workhorse
devices alright so let me talk about
some of the capabilities of these probes
so they're you're useful for record
action potentials but there's other
things that they can do that would be
very difficult to do with a
conventionally sized group and all of
these beautiful images I'm going to show
you were done in that one size lab so
what you're seeing at the top there is a
rat brain where we have done the slicing
with the electrodes in place so remember
these are smaller than neurons and so
while it's really hard to slice a
normal-sized Pro because you're either
gonna break your blade or it's gonna
move the tissue as you break it you know
it's really hard to leave that in there
and people usually pull the electrode
out and then they find it based on the
scar four carbon fibers we can just
leave them in and as we slice they
appear as little black dots what you're
looking at there is a light field image
from the microscope with a lot of black
dots and I should say that you know that
the little flecks of carbon sometimes
they stay in the tissue slice sometimes
they don't
the key is actually knowing where they
are because once you should you know
where the hole is you know you know
which hole comes from carbon fiber
rather than capillary it's really
obvious so as soon as you know the
location or roughly the area that it
should be you can find the hole and you
know I can my students can circle the
hole all the way down to and it's just
like we larger than the carbon fiber
itself so now we can take those black
dots and we know where the electrodes
are on our other images and now you can
combine these slice in place electrode
positions with any staining of your
choice and it's part of our brain
initiative project you're trying to put
together a menu of this theme that you
can use in combination with the carbon
fibers so red dots here are electrodes
and the green dots here are neurons and
importantly this is 11 weeks after
impact so
any scarring process that was gonna
happen
should have set in by now so you can see
here here's two electrodes they moved a
little bit in implantation and ended up
about 30 microns apart and there's two
neurons settled in between them at 11
weeks after implants quicken I mentioned
we can also we can circle these holes
all the way down and we believe we can
identify the tips of the electrodes
because these holes disappear pretty
quickly and we've used that to start
doing 3d reconstructions of the neurons
surrounding the electrode tips so let me
go ahead and play a movie of what that
looks like
okay so you can see if at those those
neurons we're pretty close and personal
with the electrode we can also look at
this across we can also look at this
across 18 electrodes with an average of
11 weeks after implants and we can look
at the neural and NC has different rings
surrounding the electrodes and you can
see here 0 to 25 microns from the
electrodes these are really nice density
of cells there might be some you know
small like decrease right near the
electrode but so far and you know you've
seen electrodes it's not statistically
significant compared to control brain
which you can see you know 100 microns
plus away from the electrode and I think
that you know well we're really focused
on neuroscience applications of this
probe this does strongly suggest that
there's going to be safety implications
if we can eventually use these
electrodes or allow you to get clinical
applications there's just many fewer
missing neurons within 150 microns of
the electrode another point let me just
go back a little bit I want to make sure
neuroscience is that traditionally the
the world of recording from neurons and
taking beautiful images of neurons
ex-vivo have been pretty separate so you
know you can you can map out what neuron
is connected to what neuron using these
really cool emerging across 50
techniques you can also record in the
lab from a freely behaving rat and
figure out the relationship spikes to
behavior but so far these worlds haven't
come together so we're really hoping
that we're going to be able to look at
these images and those 3d positions of
the neurons and what
we know it's going to be difficult we're
really hoping that we can associate
particular waveforms with particular
neurons and eventually be able to record
from a neuron and then see what other
neurons in the brain anything else -
should also say that the yield of
neurons that we're getting you know
you'd expect the yield of the neurons to
be very high if you're having these very
high densities near the electrode tip in
summer earlier
histology work and and some from other
groups there was very you know minimal
damage to the neurons and you know this
we saw this in the literature before we
were able to splice the electrodes and
visualize them we thought that there was
very little of you responds but we
always have suspiciously low yield of
neurons even though we were having such
a good room immune response so my
students Alyssa well II figured out that
this was probably because of our
manufacturing of the carbon fibers and
you can see in the upper left we switch
from scissor cut some laser cuts and
this was a night and day in terms of how
many of our electrodes we're picking at
neurons so now everything kind of makes
sense where you know you see a lot of
electrodes with neurons very close by
and now we generally record a neuron
from most of our channels so I'm showing
you a cute data you can see our new
chronic data and coming paper but
looking at you know 97% of the
electrodes recorded a spike that was
greater than 100 microvolts and a full
24 percent of our electrodes recorded a
spike that was 500 or more
so again you know the existing arrays
that we've been using a pretty good like
I we still use mute I rainy for all
three machine interface experiments in
my lab but I think it is fair to say
that we would be recording a lot more
neurons if we didn't have some of the
scarring problems that were associated
with with conventional probes and we
really want to see
this kind of yield on a you know one day
with human devotes so we're very
grateful with the brain initiative for
funding us to do you know essentially
work out all of our bugs including a
range of devices that are going to be
useful to people studying brain areas
all over the brain so we finally settled
on doing a three millimeter a six
millimeter and a nine millimeter device
though there's carbon fiber at the very
tip you can probably see there's grated
you know these chunks are gradually
expanding some of them as we go up and
that's the look into there just to get
you know supports for example to get
more than 500 microns into the brain and
that three millimeter device is really
intended for recording from cortex where
it's just good to have some strain
released but on the probes with that
extra sort of millimeter or so so we
tell you most of the time went into the
cleanroom portion so it just takes a
long time where you know we finally sort
of said lots of things we were trying to
keep all this so within as small as
possible
we think we finally settled on the
design reliably inserts every time and
so where this project is that is we just
mean 130 devices and we're very grateful
to our beta testers go to agreed to test
them and we're implanting the primary
motor cortex so we can make these on a
variety of connectors as we've had to
for some of our collaborators and I
should say that we can actually we can
use all of our techniques to make a
dopamine sensing carbon fiber as well
it's a little bit different and how you
prepare the tip of the electrode but you
know this is a singing carbon fiber
that's used to some dopamine and we also
went ahead and did ten states that's
appropriate to recording the using fast
and cyclic voltammetry
we also been really fortunate to be able
to distribute mostly our existing
workhorse devices and this was done
through the neurone X Mint program that
at the University of Michigan run by an
oosik moon where I'm able to have a
full-time technician who has just been
making devices for neuroscience labs all
over the country so you know if you
google neuro next mints or you know
neuro next Michigan it'll bring out the
website and you can click on curve in
micro threads and if you fill out the
form it sends a request directly to my
technician and we have a datasheet up
there for devices that we have available
but I'll mention that most people who
contacted us have wanted something
slightly different and my awesome
technician Juliana has done a really
good job trying to accommodate as many
requests as possible so we've so far
distributed on the order of three
hundred devices you can see the you know
all the different versity news where
we've sent devices so far it's about
equally we need a little bit more that's
50/50 split between our internal
collaborators which use it many more
devices and some of our external
collaborators who have you know gotten a
subset of probes to try them out but
about 300 devices and you know we still
have a few years left on this
distribution program and I should say
we're hoping to work can be new brain
initiative devices into our distribution
efforts so as soon as possible so I like
to end my talks talking about we're
really not the only game in town or
neuron size electrodes so I think we
were the first to do like an array of
linearly space yes neuron size the
lectures but there's definitely other
electrodes out there so that the mesh
liebherr lab was pictured on the bottom
left that has you know very very small
elements and you can see there it's
living happily in a field of neurons
with the neurons has nominal density you
have did a 10 micron across version so
it's both very small and flexible and in
the upper right there's you can see that
red line living happily in a bed of
capillaries apparently without
disturbing anything around it it's on
the bottom is the place is made in
kailash lab and that's which another
example of a you know a high Young's
modulus probe similar to the carbon
fibers and they have showed remarkably
little bleeding associated with these
electrodes which is which makes sense
because they're you know very small in
size and they might fit between you know
between the holes in the cells and not
necessarily have to do as much damage to
make their way the brain so you'll see
that you know the Tommies electrode
they're very recent this has very much
been something that happened over the
last five years most if not all of these
groups have been funded by the brain
initiative and so I think that you know
in the future we're gonna look back on
this time as you know the time when
engineers figured out how to make a wire
live in harmony with the nervous this
one and so obviously you know these are
primarily being developed as
neuroscience tools and that's a you know
incredibly important for trying to
understand the brain by recording from a
lot more of it at the same time but I
think it's it's safe to imagine that
over the next ten years you know at
least some of the cellular scale probes
are gonna start making their way into
medical applications I think they are
you know ultimately you know well others
we've created other problems and you
know we've materials challenges are are
significant I think that these kinds of
probes are ultimately going to be a lot
safer for large-scale implementation so
with that I just want to fun I thank my
funding sources particularly I want to
thank
NSF and NIH for funding both the
development and the distribution of the
carbon fiber electrodes serious picture
in my lab and all of people that did the
work that I referred to group and all of
our wonderful collaborators including
over our carbon fiber beta testers so
I'd be happy to take your questions via
email and I think the host for inviting
me to participate in this event